[Musique]
un drôle de rythmes accompagne chaque
matin les allées du jardin de l'état
des bruits qui se justifie par une
activité manuelle et cela depuis de
nombreuses années
oui tout ici on fait à la main on
désherbe à la main parce que on a un peu
moins cinq ans
mais puis le produit on me fait tout la
même
dans les gazons si elle est mauvaise et
à montirat la main même dans les
parterres pareil ça prend un peu plus de
temps mais c'est beau fasse trop répéter
répéter ça ça repousse plus jamais de
produits de nikon est ce que ça devient
intéressant manuellement la main 2017
est en effet marqué par an projet de loi
sur la transition énergétique qui
interdit toute collectivité d'utiliser
des produits phytosanitaires
une mesure essentielle mais au
département malgré la pénibilité de la
tâche ces considérations écologiques
font leur quotidien comme zone fait
vraiment sec parce qu'il y avait la fête
pas trop longtemps d'un jardin mais les
gens ont beaucoup pique-niqué la preuve
les feux d'artifice le manège et oui bon
on laisse assez déçu mais après on
refait et la situation va pas dire les
infos passés sur gazon la phase i après
qu'elle a fait et fini naturel
tout le monde est content une fois la
partie désherbage manuel terminée c'est
avec de l'engrais naturel que les
pelouses sont relancés et le cercle
vertueux ne s'arrête pas là avec du
compostage manuel
mais
si l'on ajoute au 4 hectares du jardin
de l'état le jardin de ville elles
mascarin colimaçon le village corail ou
encore le jardin de régler les espaces
verts du département sont choyés chaque
jour au naturel
[Musique]